im jahr 2030 japanische wissenschaftler
wollen erstmals bis zum erdmantel poren
um proben zu entnehmen ja krass alter
vielleicht treffen sie dabei auf mein
niveau
ich finde mein neues alpaka dahin paris
athen auf wiedersehen heute soll es
nicht um das neue ein paar kammer im
hintergrund gehen sondern darum dass
sich in den letzten tagen sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr viele videos
gesehen habe was ich 2020 alles zu
ändern wird
und ich hab mir gedacht bevor ich euch
sachen zeige die sich 2020 ändern zeige
ich euch dinge die sich als gemeinde den
nächsten jahrtausenden millionen ändern
werden
starten wir allerdings erst mal bei 2020
und zwar sollen ab diesem jahr roboter
ekso skelette die es senioren leichter
machen sich zu bewegen auf den markt
kommen und das bräuchte ich auch wenn
ich irgendwie zur arbeit gehen müsste
oder so einfach so ein ding dann könnte
nebenbei noch ein bisschen weiter penan
außerdem werden in diesem jahr mehr
menschen auf der welt ein handy besitzen
als es menschen mit zugang zu strom gibt
j
[Musik]
die heute ein handy haben als menschen
die zugangs strom haben dann können noch
mehr leute gar nicht handy laden
auch in 2020 der saudi-arabische jd
power wird fertig und es damit das
höchste gebäude der welt ich hoffe die
spielen musik im aufzug allerdings was
da schon mit den neuerungen für das jahr
2020 klar könnte ich euch jetzt
beispielsweise auch sowas sagen wie das
bahnfahren günstiger wir jetzt fliegen
wir teurer und beispielsweise whatsapp
führt werbung ein in den stories und in
den staat osten allgemein wer nutzt noch
richtig whatsapp status service machen
wir allerdings nun weiter mit dem jahr
2021 und zwar wird dann die us airforce
zum ersten mal kampfjet mit laserwaffen
ausstatten und das geht dann komplett
star wars sein machen allerdings sei
weiter mit dem jahr nach 2021 nämlich
richtig 4923 und 22 zum ersten mal die
nasa und esa gemeinsam versuchen die
umlaufbahn eines asteoriden zu verändern
und ich drück an türen an den zielen
steht außerdem will china 2022 seine
dritte space station in die
erdumlaufbahn schicken ich wusste nicht
mal dass die überhaupt schon der zweite
da offen dahin haben machen wir nun
allerdings weiter mit dem jahr 2024 und
zweifel dort spacex also das unternehmen
von elon musk beziehungsweise was auch
zu testen und so weiter gehört die
wollen die ersten menschen zum mars
schicken und das real tor
mich reizt der weltraum überhaupt nicht
der leute die sagen boah voll geil
unendliche weiten heißt auf exchange
hier in australien ich will zum jupiter
abhängig bin glücklich in köln im jahr
2025 die braun verschriebene medikamente
in unserer eigenen küche und das kann
ich mir ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht
vorstellen
2025 noch so voll weit weg aber das ist
einfach in verdammt nochmal fünf jahren
als wenn ich dann da oben stehe und
mitdenken rezept verschrieben bekommen
das heißt ich brauche mir jetzt selbst
meine aspirin gegen mein vater oder
meine ibuprofen gegen meine
kopfschmerzen oder 1
und dann verkackt segen was macht sie
aus asien sind gift rang im jahr 2026
der 1882 begonnene bau der sagrada
familia wird endlich abgeschlossen sein
ja in der geschwindigkeit habe ich immer
referate geschrieben im jahr 2026 ein in
frankreich gebaute experimenteller
fusionsreaktor wird zum ersten mal
eingeschaltet mit ihm geht die
möglichkeit einer praktisch
unerschöpflichen energiequelle erforscht
tschüss atomkraftwerke und ich bräuchten
erschöpfende gespräch quelle im jahr
2027 insekten ähnliche roboter sollen
eingesetzt werden um pflanzen zu
bestäuben alles klar
brauchbar keine insekten mehr im jahr
2030 japanische wissenschaftler wollen
erstmals bis zum erdmantel bohren um
proben zu entnehmen ja krass alter
vielleicht treffen sie dabei auf mein
niveau auch im jahr 2030 will spacex die
erste stadt auf dem mars bauen das heißt
im jahr 2024
in vier jahren sollen die ersten
menschen zum abmarsch also in vier
jahren sollen die ersten menschen zum
beispiel
[Musik]
in vier jahren sollen die ersten
menschen zum mars geschickt werden und
dann sechs jahre später soll dann der
ganzen stadt stehen aufmarsch ich komm
lass mich in ruhe mit dem namen von 2030
bis 2036 soll die aktivität der sonne um
60 prozent fallen und die erde eine
kältephase durchleben die einer mini
eiszeit gleicht mein gott kann ich mein
bier draußen lagern zwei jahre später
also im jahr 2038 muss dann der fifa
wm-pokal ausgetauscht werden weil an
seiner unterseite kein platz mehr für
neue gewinnernamen ist okay die ganze
zeit zu fakten über raumfahrt die
erderwärmung und dann geht's halt um den
wm-pokal der leiter ausgetauscht werden
muss weil auf der rückseite kein platz
mehr ist im jahr 2040 satelliten sammeln
sollen energie direkt in der
erdumlaufbahn und schicken diese zur
erde und ich stehe immer noch ein
usb-kabel fall sturmreihen allgemein
muss man allerdings mal sagen das ist
wirklich ab jetzt erst so richtig
interessant wird also jetzt kommt so die
krassen zeitabstände jetzt nicht mehr so
ein jahr oder zwei jahre differenz
sondern nachher sind wir beide neuer was
in einer millionen jahren passiert in
unserem planeten allerdings waren wir
erstmal direkt weiter mit dem jahr 2000
49 und zwar wird da die unfallstelle der
nuklearkatastrophe von fukushima endlich
aufgeräumt sein ja da werde ich dann
vielleicht auch mal schaffen meine
wohnung aufgeräumt zu haben
bringen wir nun allerdings direkt in die
2050 er und zwar kann man das nicht
genau auf ein ja irgendwie festlegen
dieses ereignis und zwar wird das tote
meer ausgetrocknet sein
das ist ziemlich traurig was allerdings
20 jahre später dann passieren wird im
jahr 2070 ist das der erste fahrstuhl
von der erde ins all in betrieb gehen
wird okay mit dem fahrstuhl ins weltall
danke bringen wir nun allerdings 40
jahre weiter ins jahr 2110 und zwar wird
dort der 2000 30 also noch nicht mal
begonnen sondern mit den zehn jahren
beginnen
da wird die mega pyramide in der bucht
von tokio fertiggestellt sein und zwar
ist die 2000 meter hoch und heißt
shimizu megacity pyramid und das ja da
habe ich respekt vor weil ich kann ich
mal ein kartenhaus zusammen bauen sofort
um als baum gefallen oder was im jahr
2000 160 der erste 150 jahre alte mensch
direkt okay es hat allgemein das ding so
zunehmenden jahren wie wie sollen jahre
auch abnehmen im jahr 2001 177 pluto hat
zum ersten mal seit seiner entdeckung im
jahr 1930 die sonne umkreist geil
glückwunsch pluto genauso wie ich auf
dem weg zu einem praktikum damals um das
jahr 3000 menschen die nicht genetisch
oder technologisch manipuliert sind was
in dieser zukunft wahrscheinlich üblich
sein wird werden durchschnittlich zwei
meter zehn groß
ja
wenn ich allgemein beängstigender in
zukunft hätten halt wirklich die die ddr
nochmal gerechnet 29.000 roben die
verlassene sperrzone von tschernobyl ist
wieder bewohnbar für menschen okay an
alle immobilienmakler da draußen kauft
wird schon mal gern dort grundstücke die
könnt ihr dann in zirka 18.000 jahren
gut verkaufen um eine million aller
heutigen glas gegenstände haben sich
vollständig zersetzt das juckt mich
herzlich wenig um 7,8 millionen die
menschheit ist mit einer 95 prozentigen
wahrscheinlichkeit ausgestorben die fünf
prozent das bin ich weil ich so eine
kranke maschine bin und wahrscheinlich
20 milliarden jahre alt werde 100
millionen rum spätestens jetzt wird die
erde von einem asteoriden getroffen der
so groß ist wie der us theorie der das
aussterben der dinosaurier herbeiführte
ich muss jetzt den baustellen hellen
bestellen um 180 millionen die
erdrotation hat sich so sehr
verlangsamte dass ein tag jetzt eigene
stunde länger dauert aber denkt bestimmt
nicht dass ich eine stunde länger
arbeiten werde um 250 millionen rum die
kontinente der erde schließen sich zu
einem superkontinent zusammen da wir
panzern auf jeden fall interessant und
um 2,8 milliarden euro geht die
durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde nur
149 grad erreicht sein alles leben auf
dem planeten ist nun quasi ausgelöscht
auch sah ich wenn ich bin halt eine
maschine und maschinen brauchen ja nicht
springen wir jetzt allerdings wieder
fünf milliarden jahre nach vorne und
zwar ins jahr 7,5 9 milliarden ende
gelände
die sonne ist jetzt so riesig dass die
erde und mond aus ihrer umlaufbahn an
sich saugt alles jetzt theoretisch noch
existierende leben verdampft bevor der
ganze planet dann in die sonne stürzt
das ist dann der moment wo ich als
maschine eventuell auch ein bisschen
hitze spüren werde
denn danach passiert nur noch das hier
stille und vielleicht ein leises
brutzeln weil ich maschine mit einem
einen burger im hintergrund beraten
werde
an der stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ich hab diesen pass wieder
artikel entdeckt also links ist
natürlich auch uns in der video
beschreibung könnte auch gerne mal
vorbeischauen ich habe einige dinge
ausgelassen es gibt insgesamt 47
verschiedene dinge die sie aufgezählt
haben die den nächsten milliarden jahren
die iren werden hat mit nicht vergessen
luca dotti 47 ereignissen hab ich mir
allerdings nur 34 rausgepickt weil ich
jemand resten von der und die wollte ich
heute euch einfach mal präsentieren was
findet ihr am krassesten ja eigentlich
war alles ziemlich krass ist nicht mal
interessieren würde von euch unten in
den kommentaren ist habt ihr
irgendwelche jahres vorsätze sander und
ich haben in einer podcast folge darüber
geredet die noch gar nicht online ist
luca sehr gut sondern ich haben uns auf
jeden fall letztens beim podcast
vorproduzieren über das thema jahres
vorsätze unterhalten und haben uns
einfach gesagt ey ich finde es so dumm
das prinzip jahres vorsätze so du kannst
du jeden tag neuen vorsatz machen aber
da ja falls ihr euch an silvester gesagt
habe hey das ist die sache die ich
verändern willst du auf die 20 rappen
das gerne in die kommentare würde mich
mal interessieren und ich hätte da auch
bogdan mit euch dann müssen diskutieren
darüber einig dass jede gefallen hat
dass ein gern download ein video der
abonniert main kanal ist noch kein teil
der lupo seit weil wenn ich jetzt wann
dann in 7,5 milliarden jahren sind wir
alle tot und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]
die zeit